[Kot-nim] Uncle Tae-ho,
you wanna know something?
There's no up or down in space.
Nothing out here is better
or worse than anything else.
Smile!
That's because everything out here
has its special place.
Hey, Kot-nim, are you doing okay?
Humans are not harmful.
[Bubs] Hey, everyone. Calm down, okay?
You need to stay calm! Calm down, please.
[Tae-ho] This is the only way.
Affirmed.
Please, don't take Sara away from us.
Take care, Kot-nim, dear.
Sara.
We beg you.
Life-form detected.
You found her in the cabin?
This is a mammal. A human.
Mama!
Papa!
[Tae-ho] A missing child. Great.
I'm surprised that she survived.
Harmful organic substance detected!
Sara.
What was your name again?
Kot-nim is my name.
Kot-nim. That's pretty.
If we find her parents,
think they'd pay us?
I don't have a home.
Humans are harmful.
Not reporting is considered an anomaly.
Get reprogrammed.
[reporter 2] Meanwhile, UTS authorities
continue to search for Dorothy.
The innocent face masks a deadly weapon.
The robot is highly lethal.
Extremely dangerous.
Report. Do it later.
-Sara!
-Will get detected.
What's up with that kid?
That kid is a fucking bomb.
No! No! Stay back! No, no!
Security guard!
Security guard will detect.
Will surely detect.
Report or be reprogrammed.
Say we just found it now.
[Bubs] The bomb won't go off
if she gets upset?
[Tae-ho] Shut up and call up the cops.
Nine, zero, zero.
We possess human. If discovered...
What now?
Leave it?
[Park] Be quiet and stay still.
-Hey, are you listening to me?
-But I'm already still.
-That's--
-Look at these other ones I drew.
But Sara cannot recharge alone.
Papa!
Mama!
Affirmative.
Do we think Kot-nim
is something to be afraid of?
-Better watch out! [roars]
-[giggles]
Hey, I told you to wait on the ship!
-Two? That's two dollars.
-Two tomatoes for you.
Yay, we're gonna be a huge success!
Human! My belief is proven!
Sara! I have told you many times
to stop doing that.
It's all right. PJ will always catch me.
Hey, Kang Kot-nim, how come
you haven't drawn me yet?
You were the first person
I drew, Uncle Tae-ho.
I didn't show you
because I was scared of you.
I don't know how.
-Don't worry about it.
-Whoa!
What is this place?
Today, I present to you
the home,
the answer to our quest
-What was that place?
-Enough of that.
-Why?
-It's dangerous.
Many of the robots that live outside
believe humans are evil.
[Sullivan] "Giant mass
of space junk falls to Earth!"
"Earth destroyed by catastrophic impact!"
Who cares if a billion lives are lost?
Not again! I'm the only one
who's not allowed to do anything!
Sara!
Why am I the only human?
[Park] Kot-nim!
[Kot-nim, muffled] Uncle Tiger!
[Karum] Sullivan is not
a savior of humanity.
He wants to destroy everything on Earth!
Why do you hate humans so much?
Because they get in the way
of creating a perfect world.
Where is Dorothy?
Give her to me!
Sara may break a few things,
but humans have the power of creation.
[reporter 5]More than three billion
people are expected to die on Earth
All defying robots are to be reprogrammed.
I grant you that authority.
Mom!
-Dad!
-Sara!
I'm glad you're safe.
[Kot-nim] We're one big family now.
[Tae-ho] You've been slacking.
Keep it up, and I'll send you
to boarding school.
-Good idea.
-Stop. Don't be ridiculous.
It feels like only yesterday
when she was little.
She couldn't even harvest her own food.
Now look what she can make.
You guys are the best team I ever had.
And my best friends.
Dad, Mom.
[Bubs sighs]
You guys know I love you, right?
You're the robots that raised me,
after all.
You little fart machine.
Harmful organic substance detected.
Eliminate.
Harmful organic substance detected!